warum machst du dir die Mühe es ist doch
nur ein Huhn wer ist nicht billiger
einfach ein neues zu kaufen solche
Kommentare machen mich ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich traurig unser Huhn Wilma war
krank und wenn ein Huhn in meiner Obhut
krank wird dann tue ich natürlich alles
was in meiner Macht steht um ihm zu
helfen hatte eigene Hühner weil ich weiß
dass es in der industriellen Tierhaltung
nicht möglich ist nach jedem einzelnen
Tier zu schauen und ein Tier das
vielleicht nur wenige Euro kostet teuer
vom Tierarzt behandeln zu lassen immer
hatte eine lege Darmentzündung mit
Bauchwassersucht und das ist leider eine
ziemlich fatale Diagnose weil sie aber
so verschiedene haben wir natürlich
alles versucht um ihr zu helfen dann ist
ihr Zustand aber leider über Nacht viel
schlimmer geworden und als sie dann so
aussah war uns klar dass wir Sie leider
erlösen müssen danke für eure
Anteilnahme und die vielen lieben
Kommentare unter den will immer Videos